now in april vice president kamala
harris she was bragging she's playing a
big role in biden's plan to withdraw
forces in afghanistan but now
she's totally m.i.a missing in action
nowhere to be found still in her absence
kamala is deeply unpopular nbc news
showing the lowest poll numbers of any
vice president since al gore says a lot
meanwhile biden's press secretary circle
back you know we have all the leverage
saki who has been front and center
during most of this afghanistan debacle
but now some of her old tweets are
coming back to haunt her 2019 that's
right circle back jen was a big fan of
the ukrainian impeachment hoax tweeting
quote it's not just the call transcript
the whistleblower complaint they hear
say whistleblower they're not the real
whistleblower they hear say
non-whistleblower whistleblower would
likely have more details we need both
and not just to call this week when
asked about the phone call between ghani
and biden leaked by a whistleblower saki
replied i'm not going to get into
private diplomatic conversations or leak
transcripts of phone calls sudden chains
of heart from circle back and always the
honest and forthright press secretary
gen circle back yeah uh you need to own
your own lying here with reaction
co-host of outnumbered former press
secretary kaylee mcenany along with fox
news contributor laura trump um i think
one of the first questions that you got
uh kaylee was are you going to lie to us
i would say jen saki lied to us
yeah there's no doubt that she did and
our own jackie heinrich and peter ducey
ask hard questions but you know you need
other reporters to ask follow-up
questions to the hard-hitting questions
you ask why did not a single reporter in
the room raise that tweet to her i can
tell you with certainty that clown show
named jim acosta would have read to me
word for word if i had a tweet like that
i would have had to respond it's blatant
hypocrisy it's political convenience and
she can't answer and the press just
simply won't ask a question about a
president who literally asked the afghan
president to lie and unlike with
president trump that phone call was
nothing president trump had unlike that
this phone call ended up with 13 dead
american soldiers stranded afghan allies
stranded americans and afghans hanging
from airplanes and not even to be asked
about your own standard that you
yourself said in that tweet it's amazing
you know laura one thing i will say is
that the world when donald trump said it
maybe maybe maybe he wasn't as
diplomatic as some of the mob and the
media they feigned the vapors every time
a tweet went out oh my gosh the tweet
the tweet
but the world
after beating solomonie the caliphate
baghdadi and associates and taking out
the al-qaeda leader in yemen
they feared your father-in-law
they respected your father-in-law
and they believed your father-in-law
that's why no american died for 18
months
look how do you
look at the comparison
i mean how do you even compare the two
they are polar opposite sean you're
right i mean you just heard from former
secretary pompeo there
it was a completely different ball game
when donald trump was in the white house
there is a reason that we could make
deals with peace people like china it's
because they believed that donald trump
meant what he said there is a reason
that people did not mess with the united
states of america it's because they knew
if they did we would retaliate now what
do we have we have a president who makes
us look ridiculous on the world stage is
an embarrassment
can't get through a speech without a
teleprompter avoids the press much
different as well um if you compare that
with donald trump who took on every
single question he was asked at every
opportunity every time he went to uh
marine one every chance he got he was
incredibly transparent more than he
should have the parent president in
history
people would argue he talked to the
press more than he should have they
didn't deserve all that time
that's probably right and now we're now
we're embarrassed now our country looks
weak and now unfortunately because we
have let a terrorist organization take
over a country not only is america less
safe but the entire world now is less
less safe thanks to joe biden
and the sad thing 20 seconds kaylee
americans were abandoned behind enemy
lines finally 20 seconds
yeah
we used to have a very simple motto in
this country leave no man behind that's
forsaken now it's leave 100 americans
behind untold numbers of afghan allies
it's not the american way people won't
stand for this
all right thank you laura thank you
kaylee mcinning hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else